to to conceal the identity of our next
presenter has called for a security
operation of truly royal proportions and
why not Gertrude Stein might have said a
star is a star is a star but to me this
is a star ladies and gentlemen miss
Katherine Hepburn
thank you very very much I am naturally
deeply moved I'm also very happy that I
didn't hear anyone call out it's about
time
I'm the living proof that a person can
wait 41 years to be unselfish I stand
here and is rather frightening we are
people of the same trade we are people
of the same interests
in a few moments Lawrence Weingarten
will be standing by my side on this
table is the Thor Bird award it is given
rarely it is given in to honor the
memory of Irving Thalberg a great
producer it will be given tonight to
honor Lawrence
Weingarten a great producer
its purpose is to call to mind the
enormous contribution of the producer he
is not really an artist in the true
sense of the word he is not really a
businessman in the true sense of the
word he is not really a gambler in the
true well he is a gambler
these men with their two cents of the
Romantic and the theatrical have
organized this thrilling and
extraordinary business into a
world-shaking cooperative enterprise we
used to loot them
and we thank them houses our lovely
jewels our love me well
man Lawrence Weingarten suggested the
Irving Thalberg award should be given
now he has wanted isn't this a lovely
happening
Larry it is my honor to present this
fine award to this fine man this modest
man this remarkably productive producer
Lawrence one garden
well my dear Kate I feel completely
incapable of responding to that
outpouring of love to have Katherine
Hepburn and the award at the same time
is an emotional package that I cannot
cope with - Alba her intimate friends
case performances on the screen have
revealed the patrician the sophisticate
and the Econo class but tonight she has
revealed to you another side of her
character as you can see she is a
considerate sympathetic unselfish and
altogether beautiful human being
and so to katherine hepburn and all the
great performing artists men and women
upon whom i have depended to those
remarkably talented writers directors
craftsmen and to louis be mayor whose
unstinting support and encouragement
made it possible for me to put the whole
thing together
to all these wonderful and unique people
my gratitude my admiration and my
respect now in thanking the board of the
governors of the academy for this
ultimate compliment I would like them to
know that this award bears an added
significance for me it was at the side
of this extraordinarily gifted man
Irving Thalberg that I learned my craft
and if it were not for my long and close
association with him I would not be
standing here tonight thank you again